It's peak pollination season and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speed. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans start at $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是授粉高峰期，我的业务正在快速扩张。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使在蜂巢最繁忙的时候，我的连接依然稳固。此外，无限流量套餐每月仅需 35 美元起。这可是个不会长久的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐吧。另需缴纳税费和政府费用。
GoogleFi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. Tourette disorder and other tick disorders affect up to one in 50 school-age children in the U.S. according to estimates from the Centers for Disease Control and Prevention. Yet, the disorders are often widely misunderstood. Many people associate Tourette's with uncontrollable swearing, but that symptom is actually relatively rare among the constellation of motor and vocal ticks that make up Tourette's. Meanwhile, for many years, medications were thought, to be the only effective treatment for tick disorders. But in recent decades, researchers have developed effective behavioral treatments that are now a frontline option. Today we're going to talk to a psychologist
Google Fi Wireless 在网络高负载时段不会对数据流量进行降速处理。根据美国疾病控制与预防中心的估计，妥瑞氏症（Tourette disorder）及其他抽动障碍影响着美国多达五十分之一的学龄儿童。然而，这些疾病往往被广泛误解。许多人将妥瑞氏症与无法控制的咒骂联系在一起，但实际上，在构成妥瑞氏症的各种运动和发声抽动中，这种症状相对罕见。同时，多年来人们一直认为药物是治疗抽动障碍的唯一有效方法。但近几十年来，研究人员开发出了有效的行为疗法，现已成为一线治疗选择。今天，我们将与一位心理学家进行交谈，
who's been one of the leaders in developing those treatments. We'll ask him, what is the state of science around Tourette's and other tick disorders? What causes these disorders? How common are they, and at what age do they usually begin? What treatments are available, and when are they necessary? and where can patients and families go to learn more. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. John Piacentini, a professor in the UCLA Department of Psychiatry and Biobehavioral Sciences,
他是开发这些疗法的领军人物之一。我们将问他，关于妥瑞氏症和其他抽动障碍的科学现状如何？这些疾病的成因是什么？它们有多普遍，通常在什么年龄开始出现？有哪些可用的治疗方法，何时需要进行治疗？患者和家庭可以去哪里了解更多信息。欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是加州大学洛杉矶分校（UCLA）精神病学与生物行为科学系教授、
at a board-certified clinical psychologist. He directs the UCLA Child OCD, Anxiety, and Tick Disorder, clinic, which provides diagnostic and treatment services for those disorders. Dr. Piacentini's research has focused on developing and testing effective treatments for youth OCD, anxiety, and ticks. He's published more than 300 scientific papers and chapters, as well as nine books. He also co-chairs the Scientific Advisory Board for the Tourette Association of America. Dr. Piacentini, thank you for joining us.
同时也是一位获得委员会认证的临床心理学家约翰·皮亚琴蒂尼（John Piacentini）博士。他负责指导加州大学洛杉矶分校儿童强迫症、焦虑症和抽动障碍诊所，该诊所为这些疾病提供诊断和治疗服务。皮亚琴蒂尼博士的研究重点是开发和测试针对青少年强迫症、焦虑症和抽动症的有效疗法。他发表了 300 多篇科学论文和章节，并著有九本书。他还担任美国妥瑞氏症协会科学顾问委员会的联合主席。皮亚琴蒂尼博士，感谢您参加我们的节目。
It's my pleasure. Thank you for inviting me. inviting me. Could you start by giving us an overview of what Tourette's and other tick disorders encompass? And how is Tourette's diagnosed? How does it differ from other tick disorders? Well, Tourette's disorder and other tick disorders are characterized by obviously the presence of ticks. And we think of two types or general categories of ticks. The first is motor ticks. And these would be like eye blinking, head shaking, maybe arm movements, leg kicking, even stomach tensing or abdominal tensing. So those are motor tics. And vocal tics is the other category, or phonic tics. And these are making noises like maybe whistling or grunting or throat clearing.
这是我的荣幸。谢谢您的邀请。您能先为我们概述一下妥瑞氏症和其他抽动障碍包含哪些内容吗？妥瑞氏症是如何诊断的？它与其他抽动障碍有何不同？嗯，妥瑞氏症和其他抽动障碍的特征显然是存在抽动。我们认为抽动有两种类型或一般类别。第一种是运动抽动。这就像眨眼、摇头，可能是手臂动作、踢腿，甚至是腹部紧张。所以这些是运动抽动。另一种类别是发声抽动，或称语音抽动。这些是发出声音，比如吹口哨、咕哝或清嗓子。
And then the coprolalia, which I think you had referenced, which is, would be using vulgar or profane words. And that's, those are, those are less rare. Tarrette syndrome or Tourette disorder basically means that you have motor ticks and phonic or vocal tics. You'd make noises and you do movements. The other types of diagnoses would be a motor tick disorder, and that is the motor tics without the vocal tics, and then vocal tick disorder, which would be vocalizations without the vocal tic disorder. motor behaviors. Now, vocal ticks in the absence of motor ticks are extremely rare. Now, I want to ask about the recent controversy at the British Academy Film Awards when Tourette's advocate John Davidson shouted a racial slur during the ceremony. And we talked about
还有就是我刚才提到的秽语症（coprolalia），也就是使用粗俗或亵渎的词汇。这些情况比较少见。妥瑞氏症（Tourette syndrome）或妥瑞氏障碍基本上意味着你同时有运动抽动和发声或语音抽动。你会发出声音，也会有动作。其他类型的诊断包括运动抽动障碍，即只有运动抽动而没有发声抽动；以及发声抽动障碍，即只有发声而没有运动行为。现在，在没有运动抽动的情况下出现发声抽动是非常罕见的。我想问一下最近在英国电影学院奖上发生的争议，当时妥瑞氏症倡导者约翰·戴维森（John Davidson）在颁奖典礼上大喊种族歧视言论。我们谈到了
this being called coprolalia. I understand it's less common than people think. Why does coprolalia occur and how common is it in actuality? In actuality, it's. In actuality, it's It's about maybe 10% of people with Tourette's disorder, maybe up to 15%. So it's not that common. And the problem with my coprolalia occurs because, you know, people would say, how could somebody do that? How could somebody say a word like that? Especially in the settings in which these types of behaviors or sounds are made.
这被称为秽语症。据我了解，它比人们想象的要少见。为什么会出现秽语症，它实际上有多普遍？实际上，大约只有 10% 到 15% 的妥瑞氏症患者会出现这种情况。所以它并不那么常见。关于秽语症的问题在于，人们会说，怎么会有人那样做呢？怎么会有人说出那样的话？特别是在这些行为或声音出现的场合中。
And it goes back to the way we think about ticks and the way that ticks work. So if I can go into a little bit just about maybe the basic neurology of ticks and then come back because I think it will make it more helpful to understand. So ticks arise in the brain. They're little bits of what we call chunks of behavior. So for example, if you reach for a coffee cup, you just reach for the cup. You don't think about it. Your arm goes smoothly. You grab the handle.
这要追溯到我们对抽动的看法以及抽动的工作方式。如果可以的话，我想先简单谈谈抽动的基本神经学原理，然后再回来讨论，因为我认为这样有助于理解。所以，抽动起源于大脑。它们是我们所说的“行为片段”。例如，如果你伸手去拿咖啡杯，你只是伸手去拿杯子。你不会去思考它。你的手臂平稳地移动。你抓住把手。
You bring it to your mouth. You drink the coffee. You put it back down. There's no thought involved. But that action may involve hundreds, even more, of very minute motor movements. You need to know where you are in space. Your hand needs to move. You need to pick it up without spilling any of the coffee.
你把它带到嘴边。你喝咖啡。你把它放回去。这其中不涉及任何思考。但那个动作可能涉及数百甚至更多的微小运动。你需要知道你在空间中的位置。你的手需要移动。你需要拿起它而不洒出任何咖啡。
It's all unconscious. And that's because our brain anticipates what we want to do or behavior. Our brain is really, like, loaded and ready to go, and it anticipates. So if I'm thinking maybe about coffee, my brain is already assembling all the little muscle movements, instructions for the muscle movements, and sending them down through my brain, through the basal ganglia, up to my muscles so I can grab the coffee. If I decide that I don't want the coffee, all those little behaviors just evaporate. They go away.
这一切都是无意识的。这是因为我们的大脑预判了我们想要做的行为。我们的大脑就像是已经装载好并准备就绪，它在进行预判。所以如果我在想咖啡，我的大脑已经在组装所有细小的肌肉运动指令，并通过大脑、基底神经节发送到我的肌肉，这样我就可以抓住咖啡。如果我决定我不想要咖啡，所有那些细小的行为就会蒸发。它们消失了。
There's a filter in our brain that only lets through the behaviors that are going to be useful to us. Now, in Tourette's, the Tourette's brain is overactive in terms of creating these little bits of behavior. It runs a little hotter. So all these behaviors are just waiting to go down and be released and turn on muscles. The problem is the filter that keeps our brains from engaging in all these behaviors is a little leaky in people with Tourette's.
我们的大脑中有一个过滤器，只允许对我们有用的行为通过。而在妥瑞氏症中，妥瑞氏症患者的大脑在产生这些行为片段方面过于活跃。它运行得更“热”。所以所有这些行为都在等待被释放并激活肌肉。问题在于，阻止我们大脑进行所有这些行为的过滤器在妥瑞氏症患者身上有点“漏水”。
So a lot of these behaviors get through. So if you see somebody with Tourette's, you see ticks are just things that we would do anyway. Moving my hand, smiling, shouting, making a noise, kicking my legs, tensing my stomach. these are just typical behaviors. They're coming out at the wrong time. So we have an overactive brain and less inhibition or leaky or filters to let the behaviors through. So if you're in a situation where all these behaviors are floating around in your brain and
所以很多这些行为都会通过。如果你看到一个患有妥瑞氏症的人，你会发现抽动其实就是我们本来就会做的动作。移动手、微笑、大喊、发出声音、踢腿、腹部紧张，这些都是典型的行为。它们只是在错误的时间出现了。所以我们有一个过度活跃的大脑，以及较弱的抑制能力或“漏水”的过滤器，让这些行为通过了。所以如果你处于一种所有这些行为都在你大脑中漂浮的情况，并且
you're starting to think, I don't want to do these, it's really embarrassing. And of course, your brain is going to focus on the stuff that's most embarrassing or most hurtful or worst. And that's where coprolalia comes from. If I'm in a situation and I see something and I say, I can't do the wrong thing, somebody with coprolalia, that behavior is going to trigger. Don't say this word. Don't make that movement. That word and that movement, that little piece of behavior is going to be released. And that leaky filter is going to let it through. So we think about coprolalia as behaviors or sounds or noises that almost always occur at the worst possible place at the worst possible time. Because the more I'm thinking not to do something in Tourette's,
你开始想，我不想做这些，这真的很尴尬。当然，你的大脑会专注于那些最尴尬、最伤人或最糟糕的事情。这就是秽语症的来源。如果我处于某种情况，我看到某样东西，我说，我不能做错事，对于有秽语症的人来说，那种行为就会被触发。不要说这个词。不要做那个动作。那个词和那个动作，那一小段行为就会被释放。那个漏水的过滤器就会让它通过。所以我们认为秽语症是几乎总是在最糟糕的地方、最糟糕的时间出现的行为、声音或噪音。因为在妥瑞氏症中，我越是想不要做某事，
it's going to happen, you know, at least some time. It's like the old saw about, don't think about a blue elephant. And now, of course, everybody will think of a blue elephant. That's exactly right. Well, what do we know about the causes of Tourette's and other tick disorders? Are they genetic? Do they run in families? Yeah, Tourette's is genetic. There's a genetic component to it.
它就越会发生，至少在某些时候是这样。这就像那句老话，不要去想一只蓝象。现在，当然，每个人都会想到一只蓝象。完全正确。那么，我们对妥瑞氏症和其他抽动障碍的成因了解多少？它们是遗传的吗？它们会在家族中遗传吗？是的，妥瑞氏症是遗传的。它有一个遗传成分。
Tourette's do run in families. You know, so we see that quite a bit. It really is brain-based. There are some neurotransmitters that are involved in regulating some of these areas. of the brain, like I was talking about the basal ganglia. And these are kind of a transmission, you know, of our brain that converts intention to action in other areas of the brain related to the ability to inhibit unwanted behaviors, to express behaviors and also to inhibit behaviors. And these areas, neurotransmitters tend to not work as well. So we used to think of the brain
妥瑞氏症确实会在家族中遗传。所以我们经常看到这种情况。它确实是基于大脑的。有一些神经递质参与调节大脑的某些区域，比如我刚才提到的基底神经节。这些是大脑的“变速箱”，将意图转化为行动，以及大脑中与抑制不必要行为、表达行为以及抑制行为能力相关的其他区域。这些区域的神经递质往往工作得不太好。所以我们过去认为大脑
is really overactivity. It was too active. And that is still part of the reasoning. But it really also is that it's also a lack of inhibition, as I said earlier. People with Tourette's have a harder time stopping these behaviors. It's like they're more impulsive in certain ways. When in development do tick disorders typically manifest? And if they show up in kids, do children sometimes just outgrow these things? So we can see ticks very young in life. The typical onset age, though, is around four, five, six or so, maybe seven, about up to 20 percent of young children in that age, kindergarten first grade, exhibit ticks. So they've done surveys in classrooms encountered ticks. So ticks are quite normal. And it's kind of a growing pain kind of a thing,
确实是过度活跃。它太活跃了。这仍然是原因的一部分。但正如我之前所说，它实际上也是一种抑制能力的缺失。妥瑞氏症患者在停止这些行为方面更困难。他们在某些方面更冲动。抽动障碍通常在发育的哪个阶段表现出来？如果它们出现在孩子身上，孩子们有时会随着成长而摆脱这些问题吗？我们可以在生命很小的时候就看到抽动。不过，典型的发病年龄大约在四、五、六岁左右，也许是七岁，那个年龄段（幼儿园到一年级）约有 20% 的幼儿表现出抽动。所以人们在教室里做过调查，遇到过抽动。所以抽动是很正常的。这有点像是一种“生长痛”，
is, you know, bodies and brains mature. But only about 2%, 2 to 3% of these kids will the ticks stay on last longer than a few weeks or a few months. So we see them quite commonly, and there's a diagnosis for children with ticks that have had ticks for less than one year. We call them provisional tick disorder, because there's a likelihood that many of these kids will outgrow their ticks over time. We don't really know why 20% of first graders have ticks and only 2% of fifth graders. It's probably related to brain maturation of some kind. Now, I know that Tourette's often co-occur with obsessive compulsive disorder and ADHD. Why are these overlaps so common? And are there even other mental health conditions that co-occur with Touretz? We know that there are much higher
随着身体和大脑的成熟。但只有约 2% 到 3% 的孩子，抽动会持续超过几周或几个月。所以我们经常看到它们，对于抽动时间少于一年的儿童，有一种诊断。我们称之为“暂时性抽动障碍”，因为这些孩子中的许多人很可能会随着时间的推移而摆脱抽动。我们真的不知道为什么一年级学生中有 20% 有抽动，而五年级学生中只有 2%。这可能与某种大脑成熟有关。现在，我知道妥瑞氏症经常与强迫症（OCD）和多动症（ADHD）同时发生。为什么这些重叠如此普遍？还有其他与妥瑞氏症共存的心理健康状况吗？我们知道，
rates of OCD, much higher rates of ADHD. We see high rates of anxiety in children with Tourette's. And we also see pretty frequent ticks in youth with autism and related disorders. And it's not clear why there's probably some overlapping mechanisms in the brain that might lead to this overlap. Again, some of these are disorders of disinhibition. Certainly ADHD is characterized by impulsivity, you know, difficulty in controlling some behaviors similar to Tourette's. We see with OCD, OCD is also characterized by unwanted behaviors. I have a bad thought or a feeling and I need to engage in a behavior. I may do things that potentially even could be harmful, if not embarrassing.
强迫症的发病率要高得多，多动症的发病率也高得多。我们在妥瑞氏症儿童中看到了高比例的焦虑症。我们还在患有自闭症及相关疾病的青少年中看到了相当频繁的抽动。目前尚不清楚原因，可能大脑中存在一些重叠的机制导致了这种重叠。同样，其中一些是去抑制障碍。当然，多动症的特征是冲动，在控制某些行为方面有困难，这与妥瑞氏症相似。我们在强迫症中也看到了这一点，强迫症的特征也是不必要的行为。我有一个糟糕的想法或感觉，我需要进行某种行为。我可能会做一些潜在的甚至可能是有害的，如果不是尴尬的话，行为。
So there's some overlap as well with OCD. We also consider all of these disorders as disorders of negative reinforcement. So there are also environmental, non-biological aspects that we feel relate to these behaviors. And what a disorder of negative reinforcement is, well, first let's talk about positive reinforcement. If I do something good and I get a reward, I'm going to do it again. That's positive reinforcement. That's we get paid to go to work. We get good grades in our job, you know, whatever that might be.
所以强迫症也有一些重叠。我们还将所有这些疾病视为“负强化”障碍。因此，还有一些我们认为与这些行为相关的环境性、非生物性因素。什么是负强化障碍？嗯，首先让我们谈谈正强化。如果我做了一件好事并得到了奖励，我会再做一次。这就是正强化。我们因为工作而获得报酬。我们在工作中获得好成绩，等等。
Negative reinforcement is if I make something bad go away, that's also going to be reinforced because I don't like feeling bad things. So with the OCD, I have a lot of anxiety. I feel my hands are dirty. I feel I'm going to get sick. So I wash my hands and the threat disappears and that feels very good. That reinforces my hand washing. I'm making something bad go away.
负强化是如果我让某种糟糕的事情消失，那也会得到强化，因为我不喜欢糟糕的感觉。所以对于强迫症，我有很多焦虑。我觉得我的手很脏。我觉得我会生病。所以我洗手，威胁消失了，这感觉非常好。这强化了我的洗手行为。我让某种糟糕的事情消失了。
Same thing with ticks. So ticks are often triggered by something called the promontory urge. A tightness, an uncomfortable feeling, an urge. sometimes it's even kind of just a sensory feeling that I need to make this movement. I'm really uncomfortable right now. And when I do the tick, that bad feeling goes away and that reinforces the tick. So in some ways, ticks can actually be helpful by making these bad feelings go away. So all of these disorders kind of have similar relationships in that area.
抽动也是一样。所以抽动通常是由一种叫做“前驱冲动”（premonitory urge）的东西触发的。一种紧绷感、一种不舒服的感觉、一种冲动。有时它甚至只是一种我需要做出这个动作的感官感觉。我现在真的很不舒服。当我做出抽动时，那种糟糕的感觉就消失了，这强化了抽动。所以在某些方面，抽动实际上可以通过消除这些糟糕的感觉来起到帮助作用。因此，所有这些疾病在这一领域都有相似的关系。
During the COVID-19 pandemic a few years ago, you published a study that found a rise in tick disorders among young people that was tied to social media use. Can seeing ticks on social media really cause people to develop ticks? Yes and no. We think of the, you know, the psychiatric psychological diagnosis of Tourette's syndrome, of persistent tick disorders, which were the ticks lasting longer than a year of either motor or vocal, of provisional ticks, which are the ticks that were not sure if, they're going to last longer than a year. But their ticks occur in a lot of other places and people
几年前在新冠疫情期间，你发表了一项研究，发现青少年中抽动障碍的增加与社交媒体的使用有关。在社交媒体上看到抽动真的会导致人们产生抽动吗？是，也不是。我们认为妥瑞氏症、持续性抽动障碍（抽动持续超过一年，无论是运动还是发声）、暂时性抽动（我们不确定它们是否会持续超过一年）的心理学诊断。但抽动发生在许多其他地方和人们身上，
in a lot of other times. So people with individuals with ticks, if they see somebody else ticking, that's likely to start them ticking. They can be contagious. And we see people that are doing ticks that don't have a formal diagnosis of tick disorder. They may be non-biologically related ticks. And that's what we are seeing over COVID. And these ticks, have a number of names, but most commonly they're called functional ticks, functional neurologic disorder or functional tick-like behaviors. And that means that there's no known ideology or known biological ideology for these ticks. They're just kind of happening out of the blue to some extent. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer
在许多其他时间。所以患有抽动的人，如果他们看到别人抽动，那很可能会引发他们开始抽动。它们可能是“传染性”的。我们看到一些人做抽动，但他们并没有正式的抽动障碍诊断。它们可能是非生物相关的抽动。这就是我们在新冠期间看到的。这些抽动有很多名字，但最常见的是被称为“功能性抽动”、功能性神经障碍或功能性抽动样行为。这意味着这些抽动没有已知的病因或已知的生物学病因。它们在某种程度上是突然发生的。你的夏天从现在开始，家得宝（The Home Depot）阵亡将士纪念日促销活动开始了。是时候点燃夏天的
cookouts with the next grill four-burner gas grill on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies, price-in-valed May 14th or May 27th, U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save?
烧烤了，Nextgrill 四炉头燃气烧烤炉特价仅需 199 美元。整个季节都可以用 Hampton Bay West Grove 七件套户外餐桌椅套装来招待客人，仅需 499 美元。这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受低价保证。售完即止，价格有效期至 5 月 14 日或 5 月 27 日，仅限美国，适用排除条款。详情请见 HomeDepot.com/pricematch。你说这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那几步路。我们省了多少钱？
Enough. Enough to get lost. Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your ocean front room. Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton for the stay. We're going to take a short break.
足够了。足够去迷失自我了。或者你可以预订希尔顿酒店的住宿。欢迎来到你的海滨客房。距离水边仅几步之遥。希尔顿促销活动现已开启。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿应用程序上预订，最高可享 8 折优惠，获得你期待的住宿体验。当你想要节省开支，而不是惊喜时，你住哪里很重要。希尔顿，为你而住。我们要休息一下。
When we return, we'll talk about treatments for Tourette's and other tick. disorders, including behavioral therapies. Well, let's shift gears and talk about treatments. I know historically medications have been the main treatments for tick disorders, but in recent years, the behavioral treatments that you and others have developed have become very common options. To tell us about the history and where we are right now and what are these behavioral treatments. Yeah, and I think the history of treatment is really fascinating for a number of reasons. So, Childe La Tourette, who was the person that published one of the first case series of these behaviors
回来后，我们将讨论妥瑞氏症和其他抽动障碍的治疗方法，包括行为疗法。好吧，让我们换个话题，谈谈治疗。我知道历史上药物一直是抽动障碍的主要治疗方法，但近年来，你和其他人开发的行为疗法已成为非常普遍的选择。请告诉我们这段历史，我们现在处于什么位置，以及这些行为疗法是什么。是的，我认为治疗的历史在很多方面都非常迷人。所以，吉尔·德·拉·妥瑞特（Gilles de la Tourette），他是发表了这些行为最早的病例系列之一的人，
and the disorder ended up being named after him, was in the early 1900s. He was a French neurologist, and he worked with another neurologist, Charkot, who was a contemporary of Sigmund Freud. Student or contemporary, I can't remember exactly. So when these ticks were first you know, started being described and people started diagnosing them, they were considered symptoms of, you know, psychoanalytic trauma because that was a zeitgeist at the time, right? So psychoanalysis was the treatment of choice and it didn't work because it was a neurologic disorder. And actually, I'm a behaviorist, you know, I have respect for all treatments, you know, including psychoanalysis, although I tend to be more evidence-based, and psychoanalysis is isn't
这种疾病最终以他的名字命名，是在 20 世纪初。他是一位法国神经学家，他与另一位神经学家夏尔科（Charcot）共事，夏尔科是西格蒙德·弗洛伊德的同时代人。学生还是同时代人，我记不清了。所以当这些抽动最初开始被描述，人们开始诊断它们时，它们被认为是精神分析创伤的症状，因为那是当时的时代精神，对吧？所以精神分析是首选的治疗方法，但它不起作用，因为这是一种神经系统疾病。实际上，我是一名行为主义者，我对所有治疗方法都表示尊重，包括精神分析，尽管我倾向于基于证据，而精神分析并不是
as evidence-based. But again, with the zeitgeist of the times when the patients weren't getting better, they were blamed for their lack of improvement because in psychoanalysis, the patient needs to work to undercover these hidden traumas that are triggering the ticks. And there was no underlying hidden trauma. It was a biological disorder. So there was a lot of backlash against therapy of any kind, psychiatry or psychology. And as soon as medications in the 1950s, by accident, some medications were found to help ticks, it immediately, the understanding of the disorder immediately swung from more of a psychological to a biological understanding. And it a biological disorder. But as we will continue to talk, when I get to the behavioral treatments,
基于证据的。但同样，在那个时代精神下，当患者没有好转时，他们因为缺乏改善而受到指责，因为在精神分析中，患者需要努力去揭开触发抽动的隐藏创伤。但根本没有潜在的隐藏创伤。这是一种生物学疾病。因此，人们对任何形式的治疗，无论是精神病学还是心理学，都有很大的抵触情绪。而当 20 世纪 50 年代偶然发现一些药物有助于抽动时，对该疾病的理解立即从心理学转向了生物学理解。它是一种生物学疾病。但正如我们将继续讨论的那样，当我谈到行为疗法时，
psychological factors are very important. So it was all medication all the time. And this went through about the 1960s, 1970s, when a couple of people started looking at behavioral treatments. Now, there had been some treatments in the 50s that were a little wacky behavioral that didn't really work. But a brilliant psychologist, and some of the listeners may know who, who this is, Nathan Azrid, who was a brilliant behaviorist. He and his colleagues, Asron and Nunn, published a paper looking at something called Haber Reversal Training, where it's basically, don't do your tick, was kind of the way that it worked. And it actually worked kind of well, but not as well as maybe people thought at the time.
心理因素非常重要。所以当时全是药物治疗。这种情况一直持续到 20 世纪 60 年代、70 年代，当时有几个人开始研究行为疗法。现在，50 年代有一些行为疗法有点古怪，并没有真正起作用。但一位杰出的心理学家，一些听众可能知道他是谁，内森·阿兹林（Nathan Azrin），他是一位杰出的行为主义者。他和他的同事阿兹林和纳恩（Nunn）发表了一篇论文，研究了一种叫做“习惯逆转训练”（Habit Reversal Training）的方法，基本上就是“不要做你的抽动”，这就是它的工作方式。它实际上效果还不错，但并没有当时人们想象的那么好。
The research methodology wasn't very strong. But medication still remained the same. and the kind of the old psychoanalytic beliefs that if you try not to do your tick, if you try to hold your tick in, your brain might blow up. I mean, it really, you know, you can't, it's not a good thing to do. Yeah. So the more work was developing on this. And in the late 90s, myself and some of my now colleagues at different places,
研究方法论不是很强。但药物治疗仍然保持不变。以及那种旧的精神分析信念，即如果你试图不做你的抽动，如果你试图忍住你的抽动，你的大脑可能会爆炸。我的意思是，这真的不是一件好事。是的。所以关于这方面的研究越来越多。在 90 年代末，我和我的一些现在在不同地方的同事，
including Harvard, started working on treatments and refining these behavioral treatments. and the primary treatment was, again, called habit reversal training, and this is what Azarin had developed, where you try to identify your ticks, keep track at your ticks, recognize the warning sign. Again, ticks are triggered by, in many cases, by a promontory urge or a sensation. I feel like I need to do my tick. I do my tick. The bad feeling goes away. So from behavioral principles, behavioral psychology, we know that if you have this urge and you don't do the tick, the urge is going to get stronger. It's going to be really uncomfortable. But at some point, your body will habituate and the urge will go away without doing your tick.
包括哈佛大学，开始研究治疗方法并完善这些行为疗法。主要的治疗方法仍然是所谓的“习惯逆转训练”，这就是阿兹林开发的，你尝试识别你的抽动，跟踪你的抽动，识别警告信号。同样，抽动在许多情况下是由前驱冲动或感觉触发的。我觉得我需要做我的抽动。我做了我的抽动。糟糕的感觉消失了。所以从行为原则、行为心理学来看，我们知道如果你有这种冲动而不做抽动，冲动会变得更强烈。这会非常不舒服。但在某个时候，你的身体会适应，冲动会在不做抽动的情况下消失。
So the key was to teach patients how to recognize the urge, engage in a behavior incompatible with the tick so that they wouldn't do the tick and wade it out. And lo and behold, it actually worked pretty well. And the way that the patients were able to not do their tick was to do an incompatible response. So do the opposite of the tick. So if I had a head shaking tick, the idea would be to kind of tense your neck muscles gently just enough to hold your head in place and not do the tick. Or if I had an arm tick to hold your arm into your body so it wouldn't move. For vocal ticks, the competing response is breathing in an opposite pattern.
所以关键是教导患者如何识别冲动，进行一种与抽动不兼容的行为，这样他们就不会做抽动，并等待它过去。结果发现，它确实效果很好。患者能够不做抽动的方法是做出一个不兼容的反应。所以做与抽动相反的动作。如果我有摇头抽动，想法就是轻轻地收紧颈部肌肉，足以保持头部不动，而不做抽动。或者如果我有手臂抽动，就把手臂紧贴身体，这样它就不会动。对于发声抽动，竞争性反应是相反的呼吸模式。
So if I have a yelling tick, if I breathe in through my mouth and out through my nose in very controlled fashion, I can't make any noises. If I have a sniffing tick, I breathe in through my mouth and exhale through my nose so I can't do the sniffing. Snippin. And that worked pretty well, but it wasn't getting a lot of traction. You know, cycle farm was still the big treatment. And cycle farm works quite well. We use a lot of cycle farm in our clinic. I'm not saying it's not an effective treatment. But a lot of children, you know, ticks are most common in children. and families were worried about using some of these medications, which were pretty strong in children with ticks.
所以如果我有大喊抽动，如果我用嘴吸气，用鼻子呼气，以非常受控的方式，我就不能发出任何声音。如果我有抽鼻子抽动，我用嘴吸气，用鼻子呼气，这样我就不能做抽鼻子动作。这效果很好，但并没有得到太多的关注。你知道，药物仍然是主要的治疗方法。而且药物效果相当好。我们在诊所里使用很多药物。我并不是说它不是一种有效的治疗方法。但很多孩子，你知道，抽动在儿童中最常见。家庭担心在患有抽动的儿童身上使用其中一些药物，这些药物相当强。
So the Tourette Association of America, which is the international leading organization to support Tourette's research and families, commissioned a work group, the Behavioral Sciences Consortium, and I was asked to lead that group. And we had all the people that did behavioral treatments, including physicians, get together and try to come up with a new treatment that we could use. And we knew that habit reversal training would be the most important part of this. And we added a family behavioral component as well. And the reason we added this is, I think I'd said earlier, that the environment can reinforce ticks.
所以美国妥瑞氏症协会（Tourette Association of America），这是支持妥瑞氏症研究和家庭的国际领先组织，委托了一个工作组，即行为科学联盟（Behavioral Sciences Consortium），我被要求领导该小组。我们让所有从事行为治疗的人，包括医生，聚在一起，试图提出一种我们可以使用的新疗法。我们知道习惯逆转训练将是其中最重要的部分。我们还增加了一个家庭行为部分。我们增加这个的原因是，我想我之前说过，环境可以强化抽动。
So if, and this is also some work done by Azrin and others. If children are ticking and somebody yells at them to stop ticking, that's going to make them more anxious and probably tick more. And that's negative reinforcement. If children are ticking and mom and God love moms, you know, say, oh, Billy, you're ticking, you don't need to do your homework, here's some cookies. That's going to be great for Billy, but that's reinforcing ticks, right? We all know about positive reinforcement, right?
所以如果，这也是阿兹林和其他人做的一些工作。如果孩子们在抽动，有人对他们大喊大叫让他们停止抽动，那会让他们更焦虑，可能会抽动得更多。这就是负强化。如果孩子们在抽动，妈妈——上帝保佑妈妈们——说，“哦，比利，你在抽动，你不需要做作业了，给你些饼干。”这对比利来说太棒了，但这强化了抽动，对吧？我们都知道正强化，对吧？
Pavlov and his dogs, et cetera. So we created another component designed to create a, tick neutral environment, the child should not be punished nor rewarded for ticks in order to support reduction in the ticks. And we put those together and that was called the comprehensive behavioral intervention for ticks or cbit because it's comprehensive because it has the direct habit reversal to directly affect children, teach them how to manage the tick and resist the tick. And the other piece would be, we call it the func shell or the environmental piece by creating a neutral environment that doesn't reinforce ticks or create negative energies or anxiety that might also
巴甫洛夫和他的狗等等。所以我们创建了另一个旨在创造“抽动中性环境”的组件，孩子不应因抽动而受到惩罚或奖励，以支持减少抽动。我们将这些放在一起，这被称为“抽动综合行为干预”（CBIT），因为它很全面，因为它有直接的习惯逆转来直接影响孩子，教他们如何管理抽动和抵抗抽动。另一部分是，我们称之为功能性或环境部分，通过创造一个不强化抽动或产生可能增加抽动的负面能量或焦虑的中性环境。
increase ticks. And we were lucky to get funded and do two large studies and show that it worked. What are the drugs you were alluding to that may help people with tick disorders? The most common, well, originally these were neuroleptic medications. So the same kinds of medications that would be used for psychosis. like Haldol, there was another one, ORAP, that were pretty powerful drugs. More recently, now there are some new classes of medication, so probably the most common medications.
我们很幸运获得了资助，并进行了两项大型研究，证明它有效。你提到的可能帮助抽动障碍患者的药物是什么？最常见的是，最初这些是神经阻滞剂。所以与用于精神病的药物相同。比如氟哌啶醇（Haldol），还有另一种叫 ORAP 的药，它们是相当强效的药物。最近，现在有一些新的药物类别，所以可能是最常见的药物。
We still use some of the neuroleptic medications, but newer versions. And then there's medications called Alpha II antagonists, which are Guantucine and Clonidine. And these are a little bit milder, but the medications are still have a lot of side effects. So we use them when we need to. We use them in combination with CBIT. But if we can, we're going to want to do a behavioral treatment, a non-medication treatment first, if it all possible. Sure. Is treatment always necessary? I mean, how can patients and families know when they really need to learn CBIT, for example? The most common treatment throughout history for Tourette's, especially in children, has been watch and wait, or psychoeducation and support.
我们仍然使用一些神经阻滞剂，但有更新的版本。然后还有一种叫做 Alpha II 拮抗剂的药物，即胍法辛（Guanfacine）和可乐定（Clonidine）。这些稍微温和一些，但药物仍然有很多副作用。所以我们在需要时使用它们。我们将它们与 CBIT 结合使用。但如果可以的话，我们首先会想要进行行为治疗，即非药物治疗，如果可能的话。当然。治疗总是必要的吗？我的意思是，患者和家庭如何知道他们什么时候真的需要学习 CBIT，例如？历史上妥瑞氏症最常见的治疗方法，特别是在儿童中，一直是“观察和等待”，或心理教育和支持。
and we would recommend that as well because we know a lot of kids, very young kids, there is a chance that their ticks might resolve on their own. And with medication, especially the medications, you know, did have side effects. You know, it really was, let's just see what happens. Let's support the child. Let's watch. And hopefully the child will grow out of the ticks. So even in our clinic, if a child is very young or the ticks are very mild,
我们也会推荐这样做，因为我们知道很多孩子，非常小的孩子，他们的抽动有可能自行消退。而对于药物，特别是那些确实有副作用的药物，你知道，这确实是“让我们看看会发生什么”。让我们支持孩子。让我们观察。希望孩子能随着成长摆脱抽动。所以即使在我们的诊所，如果孩子非常小或者抽动非常轻微，
we probably would say let's watch and wait. we are always, always going to teach the families that environmental intervention. Ignore the ticks. The child should gain nothing or lose anything because of the ticks. The child should still go to school, should still have friends, should go to birthday parties, whatever it is with the ticks. We don't want the child to be treated any differently than a child without ticks because that, again, will help build some resilience and we want,
我们可能会说让我们观察和等待。我们总是、总是会教导家庭进行环境干预。忽略抽动。孩子不应该因为抽动而得到任何东西或失去任何东西。孩子仍然应该去上学，仍然应该有朋友，应该去参加生日派对，无论是什么，都要带着抽动。我们不希望孩子受到与没有抽动的孩子不同的对待，因为那同样有助于建立一些韧性，我们希望，
and then we'll see what happens. Most kids do end up, you know, if kids are having ticks that are seven, eight years old, and even if they're going to be potentially temporary, we may try CBIT with them because it's a pretty simple treatment. And it's not that hard to do. So if we can shorten the duration of the ticks or potentially prevent worsening ticks with the behavioral intervention, we can do that. But children that are a bit younger than that, the treatment may be more difficult.
然后我们会看看会发生什么。大多数孩子最终会，你知道，如果孩子七、八岁时有抽动，即使它们可能是暂时的，我们也可能会尝试 CBIT，因为它是一种相当简单的治疗方法。而且做起来并不难。所以如果我们能缩短抽动的时间或可能通过行为干预防止抽动恶化，我们可以这样做。但比那更小的孩子，治疗可能更困难。
There we would watch and wait. What got you interested in this line of research? I actually was an OCD researcher. And I moved to UCLA from Columbia University in 1995 to start an OCD program, a treatment program, again, using behavior therapy. And we started seeing a lot of kids with comorbid ticks. So my boss said, you need to learn about ticks. And he sent me to a support meeting. a Tourette's, a parent's support group for kids with Tourette's.
在那里我们会观察和等待。是什么让你对这一研究方向感兴趣？我实际上是一名强迫症研究员。我于 1995 年从哥伦比亚大学搬到加州大学洛杉矶分校，开始了一个强迫症项目，一个治疗项目，同样是使用行为疗法。我们开始看到很多患有共病抽动的孩子。所以我的老板说，你需要了解抽动。他把我送到了一次支持会议上。一个妥瑞氏症，一个为患有妥瑞氏症的孩子提供的家长支持小组。
And I went to this meeting and they said, oh, we're so glad you're here. We have all these questions. And I said, no, I don't know anything about Ticks. I'm here to learn from you. And they all looked at me, you know, with this surprise. And then they realized what a great opportunity. So that was my start. And so I take it there are support groups around the country for people who are listening
我去参加了这个会议，他们说，“哦，我们很高兴你在这里。我们有所有这些问题。”我说，“不，我对抽动一无所知。我是来向你们学习的。”他们都看着我，你知道，带着惊讶。然后他们意识到这是一个多么好的机会。所以那是我的开始。所以我想全国各地都有为听众提供的支持小组，
if they're interested in joining one. How do they find one? Yeah, if I can, the Tourette Association of America. I think it's Tourette.org or TAA.org is an amazing resource. They have lists of support groups. They have tons of material. I work quite closely with them, and they can provide support. Or, you know, you can go online or, you know, just look for Tourette support group in your area.
如果他们有兴趣加入一个的话。他们怎么找到一个？是的，如果可以的话，美国妥瑞氏症协会。我想是 Tourette.org 或 TAA.org，这是一个了不起的资源。他们有支持小组的名单。他们有大量的材料。我与他们密切合作，他们可以提供支持。或者，你知道，你可以上网，或者，你知道，只需在你的地区寻找妥瑞氏症支持小组。
Seabit is becoming much more common. And again, going back to the Tourette Association, they were our partners on this grant. It was the CBIT treatment studies were supported by the National Institute of Mental Health with the TRED Association as a partner. And once we completed the study and showed that the treatment was very safe and effective, they created a program to disseminate these details. So they sent us all over the country to give talks and do workshops and support the dissemination of this treatment. So it's actually pretty well available in a number of places now as a result of that.
CBIT 变得越来越普遍。同样，回到妥瑞氏症协会，他们是我们这项拨款的合作伙伴。CBIT 治疗研究得到了美国国家心理健康研究所的支持，妥瑞氏症协会作为合作伙伴。一旦我们完成了研究并证明该疗法非常安全有效，他们就创建了一个项目来传播这些细节。所以他们派我们到全国各地进行演讲、举办研讨会并支持这种疗法的传播。所以由于这个原因，它现在在许多地方实际上相当容易获得。
Are there any other myths or misconceptions about Tourette syndrome that we haven't covered? That's a good question. You know, individuals with Tourette's are just like anybody else. They're just as smart. They're just as funny. They're just as athletic. I think that's been something of trying to kind of destigmatize or demystify Tourette's. Going back to kind of before the behavioral treatments, when we're really, we're really,
关于妥瑞氏症，还有我们没有涵盖的神话或误解吗？这是一个好问题。你知道，妥瑞氏症患者和任何人一样。他们一样聪明。他们一样有趣。他们一样有运动天赋。我认为这一直是试图去污名化或揭开妥瑞氏症神秘面纱的一部分。回到行为疗法之前，当我们真的、真的
really no good treatments. There was medication. The idea was that these kids needed to be sheltered because we knew that stress increased ticks, and these kids were patientized. They were treated almost as invalids and just keep quiet, let's not stress. You really shouldn't go out. You shouldn't do other things, you know, because you don't have that capacity. Because people learn very early on that stress, anxiety, attention would worsen ticks. Again, like I was saying before, if a child is in a situation where they're afraid to tick, they're likely going to tick. And what we learned through our treatment, the behavioral treatment is, you know, don't hide, but, you know, seek out and believe in yourself and push yourself and go into these situations.
真的没有好的治疗方法时。有药物。当时的想法是这些孩子需要被保护，因为我们知道压力会增加抽动，而这些孩子被“病人化”了。他们几乎被当作残疾人对待，只是保持安静，让我们不要有压力。你真的不应该出去。你不应该做其他事情，你知道，因为你没有那种能力。因为人们很早就知道压力、焦虑、注意力会加重抽动。同样，就像我之前说的，如果一个孩子处于害怕抽动的情况下，他们很可能会抽动。我们通过我们的治疗，行为治疗学到的是，你知道，不要躲藏，但是，你知道，去寻找并相信自己，推动自己，进入这些情况。
We want you to lead a normal life. We want you to push and be out there and be active and have and have faith and confidence that you're going to be able to do these treatments. And in fact, that was a big turning point. And I think the way we understood Tix is a result of some of these behavioral work that we and many others have done is you need to get out in society and live your life and face the challenges and be accepted. The other issue is that people don't really understand Tourette's in the community, and especially with coprolalia.
我们希望你过正常的生活。我们希望你推动自己，走出去，保持活跃，并有信心，相信你能够进行这些治疗。事实上，这是一个巨大的转折点。我认为我们理解抽动的方式是我们和其他许多人所做的一些行为工作的结果，你需要走进社会，过你的生活，面对挑战并被接受。另一个问题是，社区里的人们并不真正了解妥瑞氏症，特别是在秽语症方面。
People think that coprolalia is purposeful during COVID when you're in a situation and you're around and you have a coughing tick. What's going to happen? Don't cough, don't cough, and these kids were coughing like crazy. And it was a tick. They weren't sick and they were getting kicked out of school. We had a number of kids with coprolalia, maybe shouting out sexual words again during a lot of the societal, social changes that were going on. And the number of individual threats got arrested for shouting profanity or shouting, you know, sexually, you know, unwanted words, or either maybe reaching out and trying to touch somebody. You know, the tick, there can be like a touching tick.
人们认为秽语症是有目的的。在新冠期间，当你处于某种情况，你在周围，你有咳嗽抽动。会发生什么？“不要咳嗽，不要咳嗽”，这些孩子咳嗽得厉害。那是一个抽动。他们没有生病，他们被赶出了学校。我们有许多患有秽语症的孩子，也许在许多社会变化发生时大喊性词汇。许多个人威胁因为大喊亵渎语言或大喊，你知道，性，你知道，不受欢迎的词汇，或者也许伸手试图触摸某人而被捕。你知道，抽动，可能有一种触摸抽动。
And it was really, really, really a dark time. So society hopefully is coming around, but we still need to spread the word that these folks are like anyone else. It's uncontrolled. They don't want to do these things. They're not shouting out profanity because they believe. believe in it, they're shouting it out because they're trying not to, because they don't believe in it. So just to wrap up, what are you researching now?
那真的是一段非常、非常、非常黑暗的时期。所以社会希望正在好转，但我们仍然需要传播这个信息，即这些人就像其他人一样。这是无法控制的。他们不想做这些事情。他们不是因为相信而大喊亵渎语言，他们大喊是因为他们试图不这样做，因为他们不相信它。所以最后，你现在在研究什么？
What are the big questions that still need to be answered? In Tourette's, well, I work one of my close colleagues at UCLA, Dr. Sandra Lou is looking at EEG, and we're looking at some other trying to better understand the biology of Tourette's and the underlying neurology. some work going on with transcranial magnetic stimulation as a, not for kids yet, but, and don't go rushing out because it hasn't been really, it's just only starting to be studied. So looking at different kinds of more sophisticated biological interventions, but the real important thing is trying to identify, create awareness, greater awareness in the
还有哪些重大问题需要解答？在妥瑞氏症方面，我的同事，加州大学洛杉矶分校的Sandra Lou博士正在研究脑电图，我们也在尝试通过其他方式更好地理解妥瑞氏症的生物学基础和潜在的神经学机制。目前有一些关于经颅磁刺激的研究，虽然还未应用于儿童，大家也不要盲目跟风，因为这项研究才刚刚起步。我们正在探索各种更复杂的生物学干预手段，但真正重要的是在社区中提高认知度。
community, because if everybody was able just to see somebody with Tourette's and ignore their ticks, I have no doubt that the level of ticking would go down pretty dramatically because the reason people, the ticks are get worse is because the more you try not to tick, the more you're saying, I can't do this, the stronger and stronger it's going to get in the louder and the bigger and the more intrusive the tick will be. So it really is a matter of educating the community. And I think the BAFTA event is difficult as it was, you know, for the presenters who were the targets, as well as John Davidson, you know, it was really, really an unfortunate situation
因为如果每个人都能在看到妥瑞氏症患者时忽略他们的抽动，我深信他们的抽动频率会显著下降。人们抽动加重的原因在于，你越是努力克制，越是在告诉自己“我做不到”，这种冲动就会越强烈，抽动也会变得越响亮、越剧烈、越具有侵入性。所以，教育社区确实至关重要。我认为BAFTA那次活动，尽管对作为目标的演讲者以及John Davidson来说都很艰难，但那确实是一个非常不幸的情况。
all the way around. But something like that, if it is able to raise awareness significantly and lead to better lives for these folks, then, you know, that may be a good thing. Yeah. Well, Dr. Pia Chintini, I want to thank you for joining me today.
从各方面来看都是如此。但如果像那样的事情能够显著提高公众意识，并改善这些人的生活，那么这或许是一件好事。好的，Pia Chintini博士，感谢您今天参加我们的节目。
I think this has been interesting and enlightening. Great. Thank you very much. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe, leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future episodes, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我认为这次谈话非常有趣且富有启发性。太棒了。非常感谢。您可以在我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org，或者Apple、Spotify、YouTube以及其他播客平台收听《心理学谈话》的往期节目。如果您喜欢我们的内容，请订阅并留下评论。如果您对未来的节目有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由Lee Weinerman制作。感谢收听美国心理学会的节目，我是Kim Mills。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。